vêtue de son traditionnel treillis
militaire kaki s'étend en chef de guerre
qu'il se présente à la et aux Pays-Bas
pour le président ukrainien cette visite
surprise était en symbole c'est la
première fois qu'il se rend dans la
ville où siège la CPI ville qui a
récemment délivré un mandat d'arrêt
contre Vladimir Poutine alors Paulo ski
ironise
avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet
au crime d'agression un tribunal
et non quelque chose d'hybride qui peut
officiellement mettre fin au sujet
un tribunal spécial pour les crimes
d'agression encore faudrait-il que la
Russie reconnaisse la compétence de la
CPI le mandat d'arrêt contre Vladimir
Poutine et donc nul et non avenu ils ne
se rendra jamais à La Haye pour être
jugé mais ce mandat devrait limiter ses
déplacements dans les États membres de
la CPI car il pourrait y être arrêté
cette visite à La Haye survient au
lendemain d'une attaque présumée de
drone contre le Kremlin attaque attribué
à l'Ukraine mais commandité par
Washington selon Moscou ce jeudi volody
mirzelens qui n'a pas réagi à ses
accusations pas un mot non plus sur la
date précise d'une contre-offensive
attendue déjà depuis plusieurs semaines
nous croyons au succès de notre mission
de contre-offensive il est très
important que nous pressions ce que nous
pouvons que nous passions de notre mieux
devant les institutions le président
ukrainien a de nouveau réclamé
l'adhésion de son pays à l'Union
européenne et à l'OTAN tout en ayant
conscience que cela ne se ferait pas
pendant la guerre